Hey,
what's going on is bill burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast,
and I'm checking in on Ya.
I know my voice is still fucked up.
I'll be back or maybe I shredded it for life.
What am I doing right now?
I'm sitting on a pullout couch and what is supposed to be my office,
but no work gets done in here.
Um,
yeah,
just fucking chilling out and I got a little half a grapefruit here then I'm
going to eat later cause all freckles.
It's a fat fuck and he's turning it around.
That's what I'm doing.
I'm turning around.
I'm not going to try to blame Hollywood for fucking given me an impossible body
image to live up to.
I'm going to,
I'm going to use it as a goal.
All these fucking pussies out there nowadays.
Ooh,
that's too hard.
Yeah,
it is hard.
Eat An apple.
Gets you a Fedex at the gym.
That's what America needs right there.
Now for this fucking,
I don't know.
What does patty cake?
We're fucking playing with everybody.
Jesus fucking Christ.
You live in a great country.
There's too many cookies.
All right.
No,
that and leave the house.
It's all you gotta do.
Fucking sitting here blaming Arby's for your fat ass.
Hating on those.
Those fucking Victoria secret models are,
are uh,
uh,
whoever the new fucking Brad Pitt guy is with his fucking Apac.
Huh?
Oh,
that's been airbrushed out.
Fuck you.
You Fat.
You ate a big king every fucking day for the last 20 days.
That's your problem.
It's not society.
It's that you have a car.
They have a drive through and you have singles in your wallet.
Where are you going to spend it?
Drive you fed s down to the supermarket.
Just like my dough.
He midsection.
I'm bringing it down there looking like the fucking freckled.
Imagine the Pillsbury Pillsbury dough boy with like freckles.
That's what I'm looking right now.
Like my fucking shirt on.
Put on a good 12 pounds a writer's room.
Wait,
you know,
you know what I like to go for?
I like the Hershey's many inches,
right?
Get that fucking sugar rush.
And I'm like,
Whoa,
whoa.
Then I eat a handful of fucking pretzels.
Bring me back down with the salt and then where am I?
Oh,
late night.
we working late again.
Then I,
ah,
let's get a fucking pizza.
I'm just going to have one slice,
four slices hot right down the fucking pie hall.
And who am I blaming?
Huh?
My blaming those whores on Instagram.
I'm not,
not me.
I've taken responsibility for my gluttonous.
I am a fucking,
oh,
I'm not a mess.
I'm turning around
old daddy white legs here.
Get up to almost a buck 86 you know,
now I'm back down to a buck 82 my goal is just to be in the one seventies if I'm
in the fucking one seventies by the time we're done with the next two episodes,
right.
In a couple of two,
three pounds of the next two weeks.
Right.
I can do that shit even though the of July is coming up.
And that's the big day we celebrate Independence Day.
You know,
wasn't that today we had the fight with the British and we said a one if by land
two if by sea and get those native Americans off my property.
Isn't that,
isn't that what happened on that day?
Um,
we declared independence from England on July 4th,
1776 we were like,
we're sick of you oppressing us.
We would like to be the oppressors and it's took us almost 300 years to get
there and God dammit what?
We're doing it as good as England ever did it.
Take that fuck.
Oh
mmm.
Anyways,
I've got to drink the throat coat tea.
I don't know why I never drank this before.
I got to tell you,
you know something that's fucking delicious as a god damned grapefruit,
not a regular grapefruit.
A goddamn grapefruit.
They're right next to the sun kissed.
You go in there and you,
hey,
you got a goddamn grapefruit and I'm sorry we only have Sunkist and then you
say,
well fuck you buddy.
Fuck you and your create a salary.
That's what I'm back to salary at night with my little scoop of fucking peanut.
Right?
I'm six months into this year by drinkings back under control.
Not that we'll bring your drinking back under control like eight fucking corona
lights that somebody left them my fucking fridge.
Jesus Christ.
But slowly knocking those things back one a day and it's just such a horrible
experience.
By the end of it,
it's like I not only do I not want another,
I don't think I ever want to drink again,
you know,
so whatever.
So,
um,
only had one cigar this month,
so I've had nine for the year,
so that's good.
Right?
It's going to go off the rail soon,
right?
We got 4th of July and then I got fucking the European run coming up,
you know,
and uh,
I was on a flight and I somehow discovered this part of sagacity section.
Natto um,
it's places to smoke.
If you like cigars,
people go on cigar affects you now.
Dot Com.
And you click on search cigar affects you.
Not a oneF who knew?
Um,
I thought it was spelled like after with two F's.
Right?
Kidding.
I just love all the people when I play up.
How stupid I am.
They just love you know,
you guys Dominic or nick?
Nah,
you're right next to me at the Applebee's.
Right?
Just order your fried fucking pickles.
You cont mm.
MMM.
Scarf.
Actually not a oneF as in fuck and a Google places to smoke.
I mean it's just,
it's fucking,
it's incredible.
So
I've um,
I've done that all across Europe,
but I just did it like every,
like fifth city or something.
So I don't go off the rails when I'm over there.
So I got a couple of days in London,
I'm going to smoke there and then I think I'm just gonna fucking haul ass for
the rest of the trip and maybe take a few days off,
little vacation,
little a day,
you know,
somewhere down the Mediterranean,
right.
Look at old fancy freckles.
Do you like this?
What a fucking life flunked everything in High School,
Huh?
Yo,
you did two years of a language.
Now you don't,
you just need to be a silly comment and have enough people get into you and all
of a sudden you too,
you too can not add up how much your vacation costs and then get a credit card
bill would be like,
oh,
what the fuck?
It's one of my favorite things.
I might sound a little more jovial than usual.
Uh,
there's a reason for that.
There is a father as a fucking reason is the great Sam Kinison would say.
I um,
I uh,
I finally bought a car.
Daddy bought a whip.
Oh look who's here.
The Levenia,
just in time for me to talk about my new fucking car.
Let's turn up the mic.
Nini,
I got to tell you I bought,
you know what I bought?
I bought the BMW bitch magnet.
That's what it's called.
No,
I didn't buy a BMW.
I bought a Jaguar.
Um,
and I ordered it.
I bought a Jag and I,
and I ordered the color cause I didn't want to be another douche driving a
black,
white or fucking red car as they may call me.
A douche.
Driving.
Driving a what does that British racing green.
Yeah.
Like every Jag was supposed to be.
Oh,
you're hate.
You're hating on me right now.
It's fucking beautiful.
Clay.
Is it freezing in here?
You notice that I'm wearing like,
oh,
you're fucking Apollo 13 jacket.
Yeah,
go turn off the AC bombers.
Oh,
cause it was,
it was hot as hell in here.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
I'm a white.
The cold doesn't affect me.
You know how I get on the beach and it looked like I'm having a heat stroke.
You sitting there frolicking around where it's in this grade.
I'm under that giant fucking umbrella looking like it was my final wish to go to
the beach for the first time ever in my life.
It of my life number,
that guy.
Do you know what somebody told me to buy on the,
uh,
on the old inner web there is Richard Rawlings says,
don't start saying inner webs.
I love when he says that.
Why I love that guy kicked yourself so much.
Cause I look at him going,
he flunked everything in high school too and he still made it.
They put so much emphasis on being smart in school.
You don't have to pick everything in school.
What was your,
when I say I flunked everything,
uh,
the ceiling,
the glass ceiling,
I couldn't push through with Cs.
And then there was a bunch of D's and then just the,
uh,
the math was just the old right there.
Fred.
Ugh.
What about,
I've never shown you my fucking,
I think there's still,
I have this desk,
my parents don't throw anything out.
It's still in there,
and every once in a while there's this little thing and I open it up to,
oh my God,
really?
Oh,
when I was showing you all my my achievement certificate.
Yeah.
Opposites attract Neil,
but it's like a,
it's a bunch of D's,
C's and it's just,
it's English and stuff like that.
Oh yeah.
I stopped going.
I stopped getting A's and B's.
Right.
I did well until through junior high.
And then when it counted
when the fucking college is going to have to do more than share,
the greatest thing,
the greatest thing I ever did was completely fuck up in high school because why?
Because if I did well,
if I did well and I lived the dream
like and I w and I got accepted into a big time college that had a great fucking
football program and I joined a Frat and I had penny loafers with no socks on
and all that just live in the white guy dream,
we definitely wouldn't be right if I did that.
Like I,
I just think I would have been doing so well in life that getting into this
business never would have dawned on me.
I would've been like,
well,
I can't leave.
Right.
I'm driving a convertible Audi.
I got,
uh,
I got the extra special cubicle and I don't think I would've done it,
but the fact that I fucked up so bad that my options were only going part time
too low level schools and unloading trucks that then going and doing an open mic
get wasn't as scary.
Like what was I walking away from lower back pain?
I mean look at me now,
Sciatica,
I think it's cured penny loafers with no socks.
I feel like that's a big red flag to me.
Like there's just something about it that I just,
yeah,
it's like when black people with no socks,
that's like certain white people see black guys in hoodies.
It's the same thing.
Yeah.
It is.
Say,
well,
no,
it isn't because of the power structure,
but it's the same thing.
You're totally looking at him.
You look at those penny loafers with no socks and you're like,
frat boy date rapists.
Yeah,
that's true.
There are a frappe way we agreed to have aggressive sex and you ended up face
down and dead in a park.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yes.
You're allowed to say that.
Yeah.
I'm not allowed to say that.
I'm not allowed to see a black guy with a Hoodie at 12 midnight.
This will be like,
oh,
he's working on an app and he just came outside to stretch his legs.
Then I ended up in a trunk of a car.
Uh,
but I do,
I do feel that way and I know that that's a stereotype and I know that that's
wrong.
Why do you have yes.
Yeah.
Well,
you know if,
but why do you have like Kennedy isn't,
you have like you have this Trump white eyeliner on here.
Oh No,
I think that's my eye cream that I didn't fully blended.
Oh God,
you're spoiled.
Spoiled.
I think that's my eye cream.
I put it on at night.
That's a bad stereotype.
What is that?
All preppy guys.
Preppy white guys or serial killers or date rapists.
But I feel like if they were to be,
they would get away with it.
Okay.
I just feel like it's,
it's a safe is money.
It's a safe thought.
The think as a woman.
Hmm.
Just go with the bad.
So you get home in one piece?
Yeah.
If you think somebody is going to eat you,
you,
you got to go with that thought and just,
just avoid,
regardless of how many people's feelings you hurt.
Right.
But like I get just people wearing like,
so how do you think white people should handle pants?
How do you think white people should handle the other situations and like boat
shoes and like blazers or like shorts with whales on them.
Man.
You got you.
Gotta you fucking got this person down or like their hair is is so perfect and
they've got their like color pop,
just so on.
They're like Ralph Lauren,
like yellow button down.
You got issues with salmon shorts and like a white belt with a blue stripe down
the middle of it.
So one,
if a guy like that came walking up to you and started talking to you in the
club,
I would feel very,
what is your name?
Is it something nick?
My name is Scott [inaudible].
Scott.
Uh,
no,
I'm being very stereotypical right now.
There are plenty of those guys that are a part of the yacht club and the golf
and glove and I'm are there.
Lovely peak.
Where did you meet those people?
I've never been,
I'm really white.
I've never met those people.
I'm just,
yeah,
I'm being,
I'm being stereotypical and it's wrong.
Do you know one time I met he wasn't,
he wasn't like a waspy guy was a Jewish guy.
Right.
And I was at this wedding for buddy of mine who was Jewish.
So I was like one of the only gentiles there and I just moved to fucking
Manhattan and this guy fucking big league to me,
big time,
right.
I was living in this hour walkthrough bedroom on 97,
eight 97th street.
Right.
And uh,
you know,
crack heads,
smoking,
anything to thing the total New York experience.
Like the first night I'm laying in my single bed,
you know,
just,
he's like a little kid bed and uh,
like a roach walked across my chest at night and I just thought that was part
of,
I didn't even kill it.
I just thought it was part of the New York experience.
I was like,
all right man,
I need to get tough.
So I was like,
fuck it.
All right,
bugs are going to crawl on me.
I can take this shit.
Right.
So I go to the,
uh,
but I'm still excited.
It's such a German,
Irish toughie.
Fucking dope.
You guys will put up with any yup.
And that's why we die young.
That's why we die young.
One day I'll let it all out and I'll do that epic cry like that Black Dude on
the the intervention because I still,
and I'll be like,
ah,
watched that yesterday.
The cry of a man who hasn't cried and like it was a baby.
We watched that yesterday in the writer's room and then we watched one of the
worst ones ever because I love the Guy Mike Schmidt retiring from baseball.
We watched that one and it's such a shame the amount of shit that that guy gets.
Cause he could literally at this still at this age,
he could literally pick me up and throw me out of the major league in yeah,
field.
I would land in shallow left,
but he just goes like,
you know,
whatever.
Like I forget how it went.
It was like 20 years ago,
a boy left Blahblahblah Wisconsin.
What are the hell he was with the dream to play manager.
He went all the way.
I was like,
oh no.
So somebody had that video manager and then they immediately cut to the black.
I got,
dude,
we fucking died,
we fucking died.
And I was actually sitting there when I was watching that,
how hard we were all laughing.
I was wishing I could reach out to the person that made that.
Cause I would be psyched if I wasn't in this business and a bunch of people in a
writer's room right now on a fucking show.
Like we don't laugh at Shit,
dude.
We will fucking dying.
So I mean,
I wish my standup got that kind of fucking left right room.
It's all are what's the setup was a tracking and all of that ship.
So,
um,
anyways.
Um,
all right.
So where are we now?
Where are we talking about?
We were talking about your car.
Oh yeah.
Your Jaguar.
Jaguar.
So like about the Jaguar,
the Jaguar,
the XF.
Are you excited for it?
I'm so fucking excited.
I'm not excited that it doesn't come for,
it's 100 days away.
That's what happens when you order a custom color down every single day.
Yeah.
If you don't mind,
can I be excited about this?
I drove a fucking Prius for nine years.
You're right.
Yes.
I've been gay bashed for the better part of a decade.
Driving that car.
Yes.
Long overdue.
I can tell you that's a hot fucking car though.
The Prius.
I've had two people already offered to buy it.
Buy it off here.
I know that car has done right by us.
Yes it is.
Hello.
It's smells.
You got a detailed that one time and then we came home and it was a hot day and
the windows were up and whatever that chemical was,
they put in the seat if fucking this baked in there and like,
yeah,
I know how to get it out.
Yeah.
It's like somebody died in there that cleans houses.
No,
wait.
It doesn't smell like somebody died in there.
It's just as God,
uh,
you know,
a certain,
yeah,
yeah.
Eat something and you kind of think you like it and then there's that weird
aftertaste and you're like,
Whoa,
we can't sell it until we figure out how to get rid of that.
You need to learn to talk into the mic.
There you go.
Okay.
You know what?
They're not,
they'll just pick a hike.
Can hear me.
All right,
I'm gonna turn you up.
I'm
sorry.
It's because of you.
Hey,
I like that or that Remy Ma just cause she's shot somebody.
That'd be fucking great.
So many people in that genre act like they would do shit like that,
but at the end of the day,
like what am I a fucking idiots?
I got a Bentley.
I don't need to be shooting people.
Yeah.
She actually shot somebody and she went to jail for it.
I don't think she's like proud of it by any means,
but,
well no.
You know what?
No,
I had to see her out and do it.
I'm not advocating shooting people.
What I'm saying,
what's cool is that if she talks about shit like that,
you know that she's not pretending.
Oh,
I certainly wouldn't fuck with her.
Like I'm still waiting for Robert Blake to put out an album.
You know he fucking flake.
Yeah,
he plays guitar.
He's not dead.
No,
he's out.
I went into a guitar shop one time and he was in there.
No,
at the,
I would run the other way.
He's so scary.
Don't go to bed with the price on your head.
No.
So you enjoy it.
You enjoyed watching the bet awards with me.
I did the whole prince tribute and all that.
It was fucking tremendous.
Fucking tremendous.
I don't know why you guys were upset about the Oscars.
You guys have a better award show.
Just do one yourself and show us how to do a good one.
I don't know why the fuck you're trying to get there.
Yeah,
our shows generally it seems to be more fun but oh Jesus.
Where the hell is no,
no,
it's not more or less fun.
It's just you're going to be able to be yourselves.
I don't know who that is.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
All of a sudden I got on this list like congratulations,
your business has one and just hang up.
What kills me to say keep calling,
which means somebody out.
It's enough people at works on.
There's enough people that sit there congratulation.
Like Holy Shit.
Is it an eight,
four,
four number?
Cause I have some weird eight,
four,
four number that keeps calling me and it's business.
But you know,
they have those machines that like just try every single combination of phone
numbers and whatever one hits and someone picks up there like,
hello,
I have some exciting news for you.
It's not exciting.
It's fucking annoying.
You know what the worst is,
is when I'm out walking Cleo and I'm listening to some song,
right?
I'm listening to some songs.
So of course,
any song that I listened to,
I am onstage with the band playing drums and I'm killing it and they're all
turning around looking at me like,
wow,
this guy has more skills than we thought.
That's what I do at the entire time.
I'm out there fantasize and then all of a sudden the phone comes on and I'm on.
Whenever it's a random number,
I just think it's some radio station that I used to do and that's always good
for business.
I pick up the phone,
I make people laugh drivetime you know,
whatever.
I'm not even in the city and they're hearing me make them laugh.
Maybe they'll come up to a show.
So I always pick up and I'll be like in the middle of a was I was listening
queens of the stone age today.
I was listening to them and uh,
what was the sound guy that ain't gay,
gay,
gay day,
day,
day and nicotine them like a day or in marijuana will haul all this coke.
I'm just fucking listen to it.
Of course I'm on the drums aren't gay.
Gay,
gay,
gay.
Fucking killing it.
Josh has turned around called wow.
Right?
Totally impressed.
Which will never happen.
Right?
So
I can dream.
And then the fucking photo ring.
He's impressed with you,
but not for your musical skills.
I know he's not impressed me.
Why would you say that and ruin this great story.
Sorry.
Um,
he fucking,
uh,
so I'm walking down the street and the fucking phone rings and then I stopped
listening to that and I fucking,
I pick up,
it was like,
congratulations.
Your fantasy as all my,
your,
your business ladder won a free trip to a room.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
So even if you know you don't have a radio station to yours is still pick up
random numbers.
Yeah.
You have to stop doing that.
Also.
Why wouldn't,
do you ever think you ever like dialed somebody dialed a number incorrectly?
Well,
I guess you don't do it that much anymore,
but every once in a while you just fucking dial a number and you dial it wrong.
You ever think you actually called somebody famous?
Like they have phones,
they got to get wrong numbers.
They don't pick up numbers that they don't recognize.
Yeah,
they do.
You don't think j Lo picks up.
It's like,
oh,
whatever.
She sounds like as it go.
She goes,
I'm just,
I'm just checking the box.
I don't have to fuck.
He says you wouldn't pick up like Bill Clinton.
I don't understand that.
Bill Clinton picks up random numbers.
Oh,
of course.
He does
know.
He does.
He's like,
oh,
could this be,
I dunno what now he's looking like very frail.
Uh,
yeah,
he's old and Vegan now.
So I feel like,
is that why he looks like a scarecrow that came to life?
If a scarecrow fucked a snowman for scarecrow fucked a snowman.
That's what he looks like cause he's keys is pasty is a snowman and his skinny.
I've never felt more alive.
He comes at you with that fucking chicken neck.
Can we talk about how you kind of lights up like in the same vein as you picking
up numbers and being like,
yeah,
sure.
How you just don't pay attention.
What stuff?
Like what happened when I asked you to get minute rice and grapefruit.
What did you bring home?
A cantaloupe and a regular rice.
20 minutes.
I thought Uncle Ben's was always minute rice.
Thought he had shit the dope.
I haven't dentally I'd be,
I was wrong.
Ben Can hang around.
Okay.
Came on with the cantaloupe.
What do you want from,
it was delicious though,
wasn't it?
It was,
but I just feel like he would just get a vague idea of like what's supposed to
happen.
It just kind of run with it like you're like,
oh that's around melon fruit or something.
Not even a melon.
You weren't even supposed to get a Mellon.
Just,
you just knew it was round and it was probably next to the grapefruit and he
just grabbed it.
Not Thinking
you want to do,
you know it's
all right.
So I bought you a nice fucking car,
right?
And you park and under a tree.
So I got this fucking the top,
the tarp that fits your car like a fucking glove and you're not putting it on
and the fucking saps coming down on your car.
So I sit there and go near.
Why don't you put the top on the car?
Like is there any way somebody could turn back the tree?
It's like,
or you could just put the fucking tarp on the car.
I know.
I feel like that she needs to be cut back in general.
Why that tree is right outside can hear you right now.
Don't worry buddy.
You're not going anywhere cause it's just trapping those weird things all over
the place called nature.
Nia,
we live,
we shouldn't even be out here.
That trees should be out here.
I'm not saying that you should cut it down and like it should be just cut it
back.
That's all I'm saying is cut it back or maybe like cut it so that it grows.
Why don't you just put the fucking tarp on the car,
putting a tarp,
the tarp on the car.
You Go,
it's soft.
Okay.
Yeah you do have a problem.
Cause I went down there and it was shit all over your car and I'm telling you
the fucking last night.
And what happens is a lot of people don't know this.
I learned this the hard way.
What happens is,
and I'm explain this and I know you don't like this,
but I'm explaining when the fucking SAP gets on your fucking car,
you got to,
I'm not talking to you.
You got to get it off.
Because what happens is when your car heats up,
the paint expands and then at night when it cools off a contracts again and it's
like a motion,
right?
The SAP and the paint become one.
It's like a tattoo and then it's underneath your fucking paint.
You can't get it out.
At least that's what the guy at the car wash told me.
Cause I was like,
Hey,
what about these spots here?
And he's like,
oh my friends,
my friend,
we're not friends.
Tell me what happened.
So I like your blue dress.
Thank you.
I got it yesterday.
What'd you get it?
Top shop.
Is that expensive?
No,
I'm actually good.
Good Job Nini.
Get a red one too.
I like top shop.
The Monday morning podcast sponsored by top shop.
Top shop.
That would be great.
Where you too.
Why?
Cause it's send me some dresses.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that fit me.
Ideally I'm the host.
I get the dresses.
So you excited about the uh,
Austrian Grand Prix on Sunday?
Sure.
Yeah.
You know what?
All you need to go is to one of those racist.
Once you see the fucking,
the who has it,
that fucking thing.
The money,
I should say Grand Prix and Monaco at some point I'd love to,
I'd love to just go.
They're like,
no,
it's a dumb American.
Just annoy all those rich people.
All right.
I got to read here
a little bit of a Oh yeah.
That once somebody had on yesterday,
uh,
he had the American flag back to back world war champs.
You gotta wear that over in Europe.
Oh my God.
They would just crunch.
It does nothing better than just playing into who they think you are.
Um,
anyways,
here Siri,
go loot crate everybody gimme the loop with loot crate you get collectibles
apparel and more from your favorite pop culture franchise delivered right to
your door.
Every single month we're talking a new tee shirt and every crate figures comics
and stuff for your kitchen.
Oh this is this comic con shit.
Nia.
A wide range of x.
You can have like an aqua man spatula,
you know,
a Spiderman jug of milk,
you know Robin Pajama Bottoms,
you know,
and then Batman on top cause he's definitely,
it's not again that day.
Sorry,
I'm sorry.
We're talking a new tee shirt and I went on a ride range of exclusive items you
can't get anywhere else from a fan.
Favorite franchise like Harry Potter,
Marvel Comics fall out for fuck was I when the first three came on star wars and
so much more of what does fallout four is that a band you're thinking you're
thinking fall out boy or some 41 and you can get all of this for less than $20 a
month.
Matchbox 20 member everything at a number.
Look,
loot crate come geek out with us.
Loot crate is a monthly subscription box service for epic Geek and Gamer items
and pop culture gear for less than $20 a month.
He gets 68 items that include licensed gear,
a parable,
collectibles,
unique,
one of a kind items and more.
This is gonna be fucking huge.
People love this shit.
You have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific time to subscribe and receive this
month's crate.
And when the cut off happens,
that's it.
It's over.
Make sure to head to www dot [inaudible] dot com slash burr and enter code burr
to save $3 on any subscription that you go.
Oh my God,
Nia.
We got to talk sports here.
Oh,
should I leave?
No.
You know what?
Yes.
Just the way you just said that sat there and you're looking at your phone.
You have Kardashians tone right now and it's really,
I'm not,
I just had a bath.
I just,
you know,
I don't know anything about sports.
So call me when we know a little bit.
Can you believe PK sue band got traded for Shea?
Oh,
I know that you were just couldn't stop talking about it this morning while we
were still,
I couldn't believe it.
I thought he was a hub for life.
I fucking hate when that happens.
You know,
Joe Barton talked me off the ledge.
He said fucking Nashville needed a staff in something about the habs needed to
be a little more solid in tougher on defense is some shit like that.
So I guess it's a good trade.
Who the fuck knows?
But,
uh,
I hate when big stars like that.
That's why I was like,
Steven Stamkos resigned with Tampa.
Like,
you know,
he's,
he's like,
I can't say a lightning.
It's such a stupid fucking,
I hate when they named teams after weather,
whatever,
pks a hat,
man,
that's fucked up.
Even as a Bruins Fan,
I'm going to miss like a,
you know,
I never really hated the guy.
He's one of those guys who's was so fucking good.
You couldn't hate them.
You know what I mean?
The Montreal Canadien fans,
however you know with this silly sucks and a little pocket squeezed in.
Yeah.
Um,
all right,
I got to wrap this thing up cause I have to go,
uh,
we're doing the record for a,
actually still number eight.
We're writing number nine.
Everybody,
I'm coming out the fucking,
what's that thing that comes out?
The Golfer,
right?
Groundhog.
Groundhog pokes his fucking head out.
Can you imagine if my head came out?
Honey,
how many more weeks of winter would that be?
Um,
all right,
that's 30 minutes.
It'll be alone winter.
It's going to be a long winter.
And I'll never forget 2016 with,
around this word is that ever came out of that hole
email about a seven night Mediterranean cruise departing from Venice starting at
eight 99.
But I don't think that's the kind of thing that we underneath the boat and we
think that's what the refugee special.
I think that's the kind of thing where it's like we have to work on the boat.
When we got there,
like 4,000 other people at the,
at the buffet line.
Oh yeah.
You can't even get a cruise for that.
There's no fucking way you're getting on this.
Yeah.
What is the boat look like?
I don't know.
It's a dinghy.
Yeah.
All right.
Well,
I don't know.
I'll have to,
I'll have to do something evil to ever be able to afford that,
but it's nice to notice.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
Uh,
that's the Thursday afternoon podcast for,
um,
wait a minute.
What?
No.
Yeah.
I have to go to work.
I work.
I had to do the pyramid game.
That's the only reason why I'm leaving.
Oh,
fuck.
All right.
Let's do the pair of my game.
Where are we?
I don't wanna make you late.
Should we save it for now?
Let's do it.
I said said we want to do it next Monday is a holiday.
Are you going to do?
What are you going to do a podcast on the 4th of July?
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
No days off.
This is how much fun this fucking is.
Okay.
That's why I fuck around the advertising.
I don't give a shit if they here or not.
I'm still gonna do it.
Alright,
so those of you weren't listening the past week.
Uh,
fucking,
uh,
what do you say?
They're a what did we do that to $10,000 pyramid?
Yes.
Well,
because it all came about because we were talking about how you just
notoriously,
uh,
sorta just guests things wrong or it was really more about how your,
your movie titles.
That's how it started.
Yeah.
You know where I go the last days of drag?
Instead of saying Pearl Jam,
I'd be like a flannel shirt.
Oh,
I'm in a trance.
This music's making me go crazy.
I don't like George Bush.
Right,
exactly.
But I knew that one.
That's Eddie vetter.
Yeah.
So,
and so then we started playing the pyramid game.
Alright.
So evidently I sucked at given clues.
Let's see if you're better.
All right.
You Ready?
Oh wait,
so I'm going first.
No,
it's your turn.
I gave last time.
You received like I thought I also gave,
I thought we both know.
No,
we did.
We both did.
No,
it doesn't matter.
But now you do.
Do you have them in your head?
Uh,
I'll,
you stink.
He was supposed to make a list.
I know what's in it for next time then.
No,
you can't do that to people.
Well,
I'm sorry people.
I'm going to hit pause.
You're going to do it right now.
All right.
They're going to be easy.
All right,
we're back.
She said they're going to be,
don't make them easy.
It's this three.
Okay,
here we go.
And let's get the clock going here.
All right,
eh,
go.
So,
uh,
Michael Jordan has won a ring.
Steph curry has a mistress,
a mistress separate.
Has One of the people think they're ugly.
I'm sure Lebron has a haircut.
Sneakers.
Okay.
Um,
they're not native to California,
but they're everywhere.
They Avocados,
they provided shade people,
real housewives,
fake Tammy victims,
their natural palm trees.
Bam.
4th of July celebration.
At Fox heart attacks.
Merica fireworks.
Oh,
come on.
That was a joke.
Yeah.
Wow.
Was too easy then.
You know what?
You just made me feel like I was special.
Come up.
Think of a difficult one right now.
Some obscure so I can guess.
Okay.
You got it.
All right.
Three,
two,
one.
They're a big,
huge animal that's valid.
You think Cheetah,
they're in the water.
Cats are vicious skirt sharks.
A Barracuda whales.
But there they can run fast during the water and they can run fast frogs there.
Platypus.
Sir.
This is,
and they attack you Barracuda.
They're in an iPhone commercial and it says at the end on an iPhone.
Can you hear me?
Now?
They were a game,
a game from the stop police seventies and eighties more eighties there was a
bunch of them in a ring jaws and they had to eat and like you and your song
and the water,
a big fat animal,
a whale or a walrus.
And in the game there was four of them in each corner and you and your friends
like hit it and they had to like,
oh,
I hit ball.
Yes.
Ah,
I thought you meant the ocean.
fuck.
That's something like three minutes to get,
you should have said that.
Hungry,
hungry because I didn't want it to be too easy.
Oh,
there you go.
I could have done better.
No,
that was good.
See you make them hard.
They make 'em hard then it's done the bit last longer.
Make it easy.
Easy.
So I'm you open when it rains.
Umbrella.
Okay.
All right.
I have to go.
100 more days counting down.
Can't wait.
All right.
Uh,
that's the Thursday afternoon podcast.
Enjoy the music that's coming up.
Have a great July 4th weekend.
Uh,
thank you to everybody in this country that's come out to my shows and thank you
to England for losing that great battle today on a July 4th.
Right.
Then they lose a battle.
Then we signed a paper like,
ah,
you motherfuckers,
we got,
you
know,
I know,
I know what it is.
We declared our independence.
I just liked doing it because it makes them feel superior and that's right where
you want them just coming in.
What do they call themselves?
Cozy,
smug cans.
And then you give him the old right there,
Fred.
All right,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
Have a wonderful weekend and I'll talk to you on Monday then.
[inaudible]
oh,
okay.
Oh
Yay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's still births.
The Monday morning podcast.
What the hell today?
June 29th June 30th date.
I don't know.
I don't know where it is.
It's the last Monday in June and I can't believe how much the summer is just
flying by
Jay.
When somebody say said that every fucking summer,
you know,
you know it's gonna fly by because the weather's awesome cause it's fun.
It's like eating cookies.
You know,
you open a bag,
you think you're just going to have one.
Next thing you know the whole bag's gone.
You know why?
Because they taste delicious to you really need some douchebag to stand there
next to you is going like,
can you believe how good those cookies were?
I can't believe they're already God.
Um,
I wish someone would say that in the winter.
Can you believe how fast the winners going by?
What kind of person would say that some Soda Mountain man was into snowboarding.
All right.
That was awesome.
I don't fucking,
it's the Monday morning for Monday,
June 30th.
Sorry.
Okay.
I was riffing and I was looking up what the date was.
All right.
As I've told you guys in past podcasts,
I have one of the oldest still functioning laptops out there.
I told you mine is,
that's actually made out of Birch.
I uh,
I got it down at the pottery barn back when they used to sell laptops.
A lot of people don't know that.
They think that they were just into furniture,
but there was a moment there where they stay,
tried to branch out into a computers and electronics.
And needless to say it's fail.
And uh,
actually,
you know what I was thinking about getting a new laptop,
but I'm good friend of mine told me how to add more memory to this one.
So I'm thinking,
why the fuck?
Why would I go out and get a new one?
I don't understand why people keep going out and buying new laptops.
Like they're fucking Steven Spielberg and the dumping like hours of film
footage,
you're not doing it.
Okay.
They cost like two,
three fucking grand.
What are you doing?
You know what I mean?
Do you ever just stop and think what the fuck you're doing?
Just get off the Goddamn fucking hamster wheel for a second and just realize how
ridiculous it is that you spent $2,500 on something and it's acceptable that the
thing is going to shit the bed within fucking two years.
It's been two years,
something's going to happen.
You know the battery is going to mess up and then you're going to go down to the
Mac store or the fucking Bill Gates store,
whatever the hell they got out there.
And then it'd be like,
yeah,
I'm,
it's not under warranty.
Can we fix the year?
We can fix it.
Book or two 50 for some stupid fucking reason is going to cause 2100 and a new
laptop is 25 so you know,
I mean,
we'll fix it,
but you know,
the whole thing is fucking bullshit.
There's no reason they should cost that much.
You know what,
you know something.
If nerds had any fucking brains,
the amount of pussy they would be getting right now
just by fixing their friends,
laptops and saving everybody 2,500 bucks instead of charging people 1800 why
don't you charge charge like 500 bucks?
You fucking nerds go out,
you know,
buy something flashy that always attracts the horse.
They liked that,
you know?
No.
Just to give yourself a little makeover with,
with the,
with your laptop,
fixing abilities,
money,
you know,
like one of those bad eighties movies,
you could turn your life into like a montage,
you know,
play some songs like the fine young cannibals as some chick takes you to the
mall,
you know,
takes off your glasses.
I always hated that in those fucking movies.
Like we'll never like somebody,
you know,
whenever they were going to have like a,
like the nerdy check all,
all of a sudden become gorgeous.
Right?
Like the way they made her ugly was they put her hair up and they made her wear
black frame glasses.
You know what I mean?
Like you still couldn't see that she was gorgeous.
You know,
and then they just take her hair down and then she took off her glasses and
everybody was like,
oh my God,
who is that?
You know?
And then the date rape is football player comes up to her and then she always
like a,
it's like no,
I don't think so.
You know,
you didn't like me when I,
when I had my hair up and I was wearing these glasses.
Okay.
But this nerd over here,
he always liked me.
So now we're going to go to the prom and we're going to dance and that's going
to be the end of the fucking movie.
Okay.
And I always hated that moment in the movie cause it always reminded me that I
was watching a movie because in real life,
okay,
that girl,
as much as she liked the nurse,
she wouldn't like him in that way.
Okay.
They can't help but send that fucking DNA.
They want to breed with the strongest cock in the room.
And I don't care how much of a Dick,
that guy,
that quarterback was being toward the second she got the attention that that
would fill her up because all those years they have in her hair up wearing those
fucking Malcolm x glasses,
gave her low self esteem.
And uh,
she,
she would at least for a four to six year period would have to go out and fill
herself up with,
please accept me cock.
You know,
before she kind of was able to regroup and be like,
you know what,
these guys are assholes.
I wonder what that nerds up to.
And by then it will be too late because a nerd's generally,
you know,
they marry the first thing that a lot of,
let them fuck them,
you know.
So by the time she,
she,
you know,
she runs through,
the time she found a fucking,
the place kicker that nerd is already married with three kids and he invented a,
he invented the IFE.
Wait a minute,
these teeth fucking event in these damn laptops they've got,
that's,
that got to get repair.
And every couple of years that's their fucking Quebec.
Wow.
I just figured that out.
That's why there's no Goddamn nerds out there being able to fix these fucking
laptops for 500 bucks.
It's all 1800 bucks cause they're mad that when they gave the fucking nerdy
chicken make over,
she's still blew the quarterback.
So now,
now we got to pay for it spots.
Ridiculous man.
All right.
This is the Monday morning podcast and uh,
my name is bill burr.
I do one of these every fucking Monday.
And uh,
you know,
I'll give you something to laugh about and uh,
keep you in my thoughts.
Actually keep me in your thoughts.
That's why I'm doing this.
I'm not doing it because I give a fuck about you people.
I'm trying to give you guys a reason to keep coming back to my site and maybe
you'll tell other people to come to my site.
So the next time I go to Raleigh,
North Carolina,
I'm not standing in front of 25 people,
you know,
so then I can make some more money and then I can buy some shiny shit and then I
can make up for the fall,
all the fucking pussy.
I never gotten high school,
see how that works.
So anyways,
I did one of these,
every week I talk about stuff that I have coming up in my career.
I talk about a comedy date and uh,
you know,
whatever,
like,
like it is a great example for you.
I have a,
a,
an upcoming CD DVD release.
I just like saying that CD DVD release,
um,
and a one hour comedy central special.
Um,
that will be shown.
I believe it's August 23rd.
Um,
it will be shown the first time cds coming out in August.
The CD,
I don't have an exact day yet and the DVD is coming out in September.
I don't have an exact date for that.
I just have a month at this point.
Okay.
So cool.
You fucking jets.
All right.
We got July 4th coming up.
Just relaxed.
There's plenty of holidays between now and the God damn release.
And when I get the information,
I'm going to let you know what's up.
So that's what I have coming up.
Okay.
It's gotta be an account during that.
So let me try it.
Let me,
let me try to say it a little more clearer.
In August,
I have a CD coming out and a one hour comedy central special.
Um,
and then in September,
the DVDs coming out.
So a by October,
you guys should all be sick of me,
but by then,
uh,
hopefully I'll be filthy,
stinking rich.
I'll have a brand new,
a Ludwig drum kit and a big house and I'll stand up there
naked with the bathrobe.
That's partially open looking down on the city,
realizing that I'm still empty inside.
Okay?
But we're going to cross that bridge when we get to it,
man.
All right.
Uh,
people ask me questions every week on my podcast and I like to try to answer
them.
People also send me in stories.
They give me information.
What do you want to start with?
First?
You want to start with the questions?
You want to go with the stories?
How about a story?
Let me scroll down here.
Okay.
Last week,
you know,
people were talking about their cars getting fucked up and everything like that.
God Damn it.
Somebody sent me a funny one and I forgot to copy and paste.
I gotta read that one next week.
But I told you last week I was going to tell you the second half,
basically everyone was telling me these stories about how their car got fucked
up and then everybody's story.
They were the victim except for this one dude who talks about how he was hitting
on some fucking chick and she doesn't want to hook up with them.
So he goes out in the parking lot,
hammered and backs his car into another truck.
And I was trying to tell him,
you know,
you're not really the victim there,
so it's,
it's uh,
it's kind of hard to feel bad for you.
So what the fuck did the girl do that made you do something like that?
That we should all feel bad for you?
Me and my 14 podcast's listeners should feel bad for you.
So here he goes,
this,
this is the other half.
This is his reason for doing that shit.
Hey Bill,
thanks for reading my story.
Share my gloom with everyone.
Ha Ha.
Let me tell you what happened with girl number one.
All right.
This is why he got,
he got pissed in the club,
was a little tipsy drunk,
got in his car,
evidently did not look
stomped on the gas and backed into a truck.
Fuck his car up and didn't do shit to the truck.
All right.
And he said,
uh,
right being the girl,
we've been working together for about a year now and everyone in this building
would like to get with her.
We've been on and off talking a lot or not at all.
It's a big company.
She's kind of a teeth.
She'd kind of a tease.
Okay,
well,
you know,
I'm going to take your word for it,
but I mean,
because she's a good looking woman who's got a lot of cock coming at her and uh,
you know,
maybe she's a little defensive.
Um,
anyway,
she kind of a tease,
but hell,
I don't care.
She's damn hot.
And I haven't sealed the deal yet.
All right.
Now I'm rooting for you.
That's right.
Go in there and fucking hit it.
All right.
I was damn sure that this was the night.
Um,
I was gonna Hook up with it because we were hanging out and talking a lot for
the few weeks leading up to this particular night out since it was her birthday.
Okay.
So here he is,
you know,
chat or up to two weeks,
he's go into patient rooms as opposed to those other guys who are walking into
the cubicle with their pants already,
half on zip.
You know,
I respected,
everybody likes a full court press,
but a,
that usually doesn't work,
especially if you weren't dockers.
It's just creepy.
So anyway,
so this guy,
you know,
works if the two weeks,
now it's your birthday.
Okay.
And uh,
let's see.
And apparently most girls like to get down on the day when the clock rolls over.
Okay.
I'm with you anyway.
I completely fumbled the ball by not paying enough attention or not flirting
enough.
That night assumption.
And I got pissed when I knew that this was probably the last chance I had,
which then led to the aforementioned story.
So basically you did two weeks of reconnaissance.
He went out there,
it was their birthday and you're trying to hit on her to close the deal.
And basically every other hot chick that walks by,
you're looking at it.
You know what,
there's not one person in their early twenties that does not have that fucking
story.
It's just what it is.
It's just pussy as to,
it's still too amazing for you.
With the,
you're in your thirties you'll be able to block out the other ship and you'll be
able to focus on your target.
And uh,
of course by then you'll be in your thirties.
So you'll be hitting on some,
a cougar as they say.
I hate that fucking word.
And I hate those broads who think they're still fucking hot,
like they're 22.
Okay.
I'm not saying you're not hot for a 43 year old,
but we stopped wearing shit that 22 year old chicks were,
you know what I mean?
I just turned 40.
Okay.
My days of wearing a half shirt
and fucking socks up to my knees,
like I'm in that movie dazed and confused.
You know what I mean?
You look at me like I was a retard.
All right.
Stop it.
You're hot for your age.
You look good for your age.
Okay.
But let's leave it at that.
Let's,
uh,
you're in your dressing elegant years.
You're in your address.
Classy.
Okay.
You know,
once you're past fucking,
you know,
I dunno,
somewhere in your mid thirties,
if you're still dressing like a Jello shot girl,
I don't know what to tell you.
You know what that's like.
That's like the fucking,
the form of muscle head who stopped working out,
but he still has the Hulk Hogan,
Hogan Wardrobe,
you know,
so he's still got on the tank cars,
but now he's got those flabby grandmother arms and it's just like,
dude,
you need to get a full shirt or start doing some curls because,
uh,
yeah,
it's not working.
It was like Billy Crystal's grandmother and uh,
Mr Saturday night number down,
they were making sandwiches out of her arm,
the fat on the back of her arm.
Um,
all right.
So anyway,
it was so when it,
so you got pissed because you weren't able to close the deal,
then you're backed up and smashed your car.
That's actually fucking hilarious.
Um,
that's a whole different segment.
The car stories I was trying to get people to tell is,
you know,
you went in to go buy some a face moisturizer and you came out and your bumper
was gone.
You know,
the whole,
I didn't do shit and uh,
somebody raped me stories.
Um hmm.
I guess you created a new one.
People who fuck up their car because they were trying to fuck the hot chick at
work on her birthday.
They and uh,
I dunno,
they looked at some other chick.
I don't know what happened.
Anyways,
whatever man to man,
I feel bad for you.
Okay.
Is a last story I'm going to read here.
Um,
all right,
bill a,
your rants and American Airlines ring true as they screwed a marine.
I met while on vacation.
I don't know if you guys listen to this shit every week,
but American Airlines,
fuck me.
Over a while,
back to the point I did a puff daddy,
a remix of their song.
Um,
when little something like this,
we're a bad kid.
Fucking you.
[inaudible]
hey h c can still get it on the air.
All right,
so this is,
this is this guy's story.
All right.
While returning from Mexico,
I was in DFW airport.
I love when people write their DFW.
Like I know what the fuck that means.
Is that Detroit fucking where?
Port.
Oh,
Dallas.
Fort Worth.
There we go.
The Delaware.
All right.
I don't know Detroit fucking,
I dunno,
the fucking guy is,
he's at DFW airport.
A K and I in Nepal.
You pilots out there.
Hey,
people do,
oh,
I need to lax.
Lax is actually okay.
JFK,
lax,
people know that.
But stop saying DFW.
Like I know where the fuck that is.
All right.
I was in Dfw airport and uh,
that's it.
No Voc.
I'm in the OCC.
Barely.
I don't know what the fuck that is.
Orange County.
I still don't know what that is.
It's south of Los Angeles.
Thank you.
Do you mean that place that nobody fucking goes to in between Los Angeles and
San Diego?
All right.
I was in DFW airport and met this guy at the tram.
Oh,
fuck that shit.
That word just makes my skin crawl.
All the airports I've been,
I was at the tram.
Uh,
I met this guy at the tram who was fuming mad.
He told me he was headed to,
to Gulf Port Mississippi from California and the plane had engine trouble and
had to return.
He then caught the next flight and then had the land in Dallas due to bad
weather.
He was then told that all swore off flights out.
We're on standby.
And while talking to the gate agent,
the employee,
he got pissy with them.
What a fucking surprise.
He mentioned that he had orders and needed help getting any flight out and the
Clark said,
sir,
I can't help you.
Please enjoy your night in the airport.
After the marine calmed down,
I asked him what airline he was on.
He replied,
mother fucking American Airlines.
They suck.
I hope they go under Jesus Christ.
Even fuck over a guy.
Was he in uniform sharing help you please enjoy your night in the airport.
Really,
please enjoy this fucking
Timberland to you.
I already said the c word enough in this God damn thing.
It's ridiculous.
You know something and you know,
just go on their website.
Just start complaining and I'm really trying to do that shit.
You know what I mean?
Somebody's got to do something that's,
you know what I mean?
If somebody fucking do something,
do they respond when you complain?
Somebody sent me a fucking email about a,
they returned something at best buy and they charged them a 15% restock fee,
which basically they bought something,
it sucked.
They brought it back.
Okay.
If it costs a grand,
they charge them 150 bucks just to put it back on the shelf.
So they still make money.
So personally I'm never shopping at best buy again.
That's it.
I'm done.
That's what I'm saying.
That's just like,
you know what,
I'm not eating fast food ever again,
man.
So it basically means I'm not fucking with best buy for three months.
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
I said let's get,
let's get on with the questions.
Okay.
Just fucking,
this podcast started off really good and now it's just,
it's brining to a fucking halt.
Let me see if I can up the comedy here.
Take it up a notch.
Okay.
This podcast is like,
it's like the Lakers in game six.
You know what I mean?
I never seen a team with west heart.
Jesus Christ.
I'll fix her up by 40 points.
They're still shooting three pointers.
You think he would have put up with that?
Kareem,
those guys would have been throwing elbows,
Larry Bird and all of them would have been holding up the trophy looking like
Bobby Clark and the Lakers just stood there and watched it.
All right.
Questions number one.
By the way,
I'm a Celtics fan and yes,
I am totally psyched and I'm sick.
All you Laker fans talk to me and me about buying them.
Guy Like he's the second coming of fucking Bill Russell and Michael Jordan.
Okay.
You guys need to work on your heart first.
Why don't you draft a fucking heart first and then talk to me about,
you know,
fucking kid a coming off the goddamn bench.
Cause I don't give a fuck.
Ooh.
Got a little hostile there.
All right,
question number one.
What a comedian does,
a comedy central presents.
Is there an applause?
Oh meter.
Because sometimes it seems like an odd place for an applause break.
Also.
Is there an opening act to warm up the crowd?
Uh,
let's see.
Is there a plausible meter?
No,
they just actually,
I think they just edit it in bill,
take applause from a different joke that really killed and uh,
I dunno,
maybe because there's a low and for some reason they think the viewer at home
isn't going to notice or like when they cut to somebody who's laughing
hysterically at another joke,
that was hysterical.
That maybe even that comedian didn't even tell.
They'll actually,
if they get a good laugh or in the crowd,
they use that as stock footage.
You know,
kind of like,
you know,
a battle footage.
You don't like the,
you know,
when they show the atom bomb it's do they have like two or three views of that
stock footage of the fucking Adam bomb that's the same.
It's the same thing.
It's in standup comedy.
Okay.
Some lady lost her shit laughing in 1983 you haven't ever noticed that.
Sometimes like they'll cut to somebody really bad,
like on bet they'll cut to somebody with a hairstyle that is just like from
fucking 20 years ago.
You know what I mean?
Like remember black people used to have the
three levels,
like high top fade,
like three different levels.
So it was like a parking garage or like a,
some sort of fancy stairs that would lead into like a serving Rome or some shit.
Remember the,
you know,
during the Bobbi Brown my prerogative.
That's what they'll do.
They'll show a guy,
black dude or a white dude,
whatever on ComicView and it'll tell a fucking joke.
You know the address.
You know,
they got an a Obama and o a t shirt,
right?
The comedian.
And then they'll cut to somebody who looks like one of the guys and fucking a
boys to men swearing like one of those lime green fucking seven up sport coats.
Um,
okay.
Yeah,
I think,
I think I overly explain that.
All right.
Also,
is there an opening act to warm up the crowd?
Uh,
if you're lucky?
Yes,
there is a,
if there isn't,
it sucks because it's like nobody's laughing.
They're just sitting there and all of a sudden you come out and you're just
like,
what's up with lamps?
But these,
these crazy and it's really shocking.
So hopefully there,
there was a warm up act.
Um,
all my experiences there has been,
okay.
Question number two.
The question is why does asparagus thank your Pitstick um,
I just liked that you said Piss,
you know,
like they should have been the f word in that sentence.
Just,
just to prepare me for pis.
I should have been,
why does your bite as asparagus make your urine smell or a,
what is fucking asparagus make you pissed stick.
You know what I mean?
You've got gotta be consistent here.
The first half,
you're like Dan rather reading off the teleprompter and then the second half
you're going dice clay on me.
All right.
Asparagus contains,
uh,
this is,
this is the answer.
I actually looked it up.
This is the first thing I saw.
So I'm going with this.
Like it's the truth.
Asparagus contains a sulfur compound called Merck captain.
It's also found in rotten eggs,
onions,
garlic,
and in this,
in the secretion of skunk,
when your digestive track breaks down,
this substance byproducts are released.
That cause the funny sense.
The funny sense.
I don't think it's funny if you to think it's funny.
It's actually kind of disgusting.
The process is so quick that your urine can develop the distinctive smell within
15 to 30 minutes of eating asparagus.
See sources for more info.
I left that last part in there just in case.
I actually tried to play that off.
Like I wasn't reading it.
Um,
so that's why it does it,
you know,
cause there's some sort of sulfur compound called mercaptans that's also fine
and rotten eggs,
onions,
garlics and in the secretion of skunks,
you know what I mean?
That's just one of those bucket things.
At the second you hear it,
just forget it.
Okay.
Cause there's no way to say that at a party and it's going to get you any
further with the person you're talking to.
You know,
either talking them into bed or trying to get a promotion that's just like,
it just makes you weird.
And people just sort of rates raise their eyebrows and nod and fucking walk
away.
And you're left with a awkward silence.
And that's when you take out your cell phone and you pretend you got to call.
You don't have a call.
All right,
question number three.
Now this is a great question.
So who is more bad ass tie domi above prober for those of you who don't watch
hockey,
these are two of the all time great enforcers in Nhl history.
Who's more bad ass?
This is tied Domi or Bob Probert.
It's not even a question.
It's fucking Bob Prober.
Not In,
not even,
I'm not even talking about at the height of his career where he beat the shit
out of every tough guy and I beat the shit out of every tough guy in the league.
He didn't start losing fights towards the end.
Okay,
so everybody knows what he did on the ice.
This is what he did off the ice.
Here's a little blurb by finding him on the Internet.
Died a former NHL enforcement,
Bob Proberg,
Bob Prober,
so I don't do the news that can't even read his back in jail.
He was arrested Friday night in Delray beach after a scuffle with Florida police
that led to probate being shocked with the Taser Gun.
This is,
this is what he's doing after his career,
when he's supposed to be out on the golf course,
hanging out with Charles Barkley doing cell phone commercial charged with
battery on a law enforcement officer resisting arrest with violence and
disorderly conduct.
Trovert was held without bail at the Palm Beach County jail while playing for
the Detroit Red Wings in the eighties and nineties probate served a prison term
when he was caught trying to carry cocaine into the United States from Canada.
He also had alcohol problems and was charged with numerous driving offenses for
over probate,
was placed on inactive status for the 80 94 to 95 season after he was involved
in a motorcycle accident and test showed alcohol and cocaine in his system.
This is what he does off the ice is what he was doing off ice during his career.
And he probably had three fights that night.
Beat the shit out of a whole nother team and that still wasn't enough.
He's like,
Eh,
I think I'll drink a 12 pack of fucking Schaffer,
you know,
get an eight ball and jump on a fucking Ninja.
Dell rape police officers first spotted prober at this.
This is,
uh,
this is for my July,
June 4th,
2004.
He's well into his forties at this point.
All right.
They spotted him on Friday as he was parked in his white BMW sport utility
vehicle,
the wrong way on a side street and began hanging out his window to yell at
several men
before one a and he was out of his mind,
eh?
Yeah.
Fucking pussy.
You know
I boss fucking Bro.
But you probably still wearing the hockey gloves.
I bet like he has to do that.
He has,
he has to drop gloves before he could fight or it's just like,
it's like no mark,
no Mark Garcia power before he hits.
He's got a fucking,
you know,
click his feet and his shoes and justice gloves,
his batting gloves or Betty.
He literally has to walk around in hockey gloves or he won't,
he won't get the first couple of shots off.
So anyways,
for officer's intervened when prober a native of Windsor Ontario got out of the
car and tried to start a fight with one of the men according to the report,
he then fought with the officers and refuse their artists to drop to the ground.
As two of the officer's struggled to handcuff Filbert,
I'm opposite Thomas Tolbert.
Shot him with a Taser gun and he fell backwards.
But probate continued to resist their efforts when they tried to handcuff him.
This is after getting tasered so Tobar used a taser gun to stun prober it
several more times.
Okay.
She's fucking unreal.
The gun shoots Bob PR probes.
Yeah,
that's that Barb wires shit.
I don't know if you guys know like,
it's not like science fiction where they just shoot electricity at you.
It shoots out these two medieval fucking,
uh,
inquisition
hooks in it hooks under your skin.
India chest like fucking eagle talents.
Like that's not enough to make you just scream like a bitch and dropped to the
ground.
They then shoot electricity into that.
Okay.
It's bad enough.
The guys already fighting two cops,
you know,
cops.
Okay.
There's little cops have like,
they have like mini UFC skills.
They all know armbars and choke holds and they have guns and clubs and shit and
he's fighting two of them.
They still have to taser him two or three more times.
So I would go to Bob Prober.
I would say Bob Roberts,
a little trough and the tied to Omi.
Okay.
Until Kai Domi fights for fucking cops and his mid forties and as to get Tabors
tasered numerous fucking times.
I'm going to go with Bob Prober and I don't have any sort of fucking hockey
geek.
Come on here and talk to me about fucking career stats.
Bring out tie dummies.
Arrest Record.
All right.
Has he been arrested?
I didn't even look it up.
That's how fucked up probates arrest record was.
I don't even have,
I didn't have the decency to look up the only,
so there you go.
All right.
I've got to wrap this thing up here.
This is getting too long.
Um,
just a couple more questions.
I'll answer them real quick.
Have you ever done any work on a cruise ship?
Uh,
yes I did.
And they won't be asking me back to captain wrote a letter,
said I was offensive to all races.
Said I made fun of Handicap People Cause I did a joke about midgets.
Um,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know what to tell you.
You know,
uh,
I was told that if I didn't I already answer this question.
Did I answer this question right?
They told me he's going to be young people and then I got on the cruise ship and
the first person I saw was that old Vietnamese lady lady with no teeth asleep
with their mouth open wearing that.
I'm picking rice hat.
Then I tell you,
I told you that rice,
I don't fucking remember.
All right,
let's,
let's get on with it.
Okay.
That's the podcasts a week.
I'm,
I'm going to tell you some of my,
uh,
my fucking,
my dates they have coming up here,
my slow computer.
June,
2008.
Um,
alright.
Oh,
big day here.
I got the Improv in Pittsburgh coming up,
uh,
July 10th through the 13th.
Um,
I'm actually coming in town the day before because I'm going to be going to that
pirates game.
So,
uh,
if you go to the pirates game,
I'm sure you're going to be able to see me cause it's going to be me and 18
other fucking people
sitting out there at the Goddamn game.
But that's a July 10th through the 13th.
And then July 31st through August 3rd,
I'm going to be at the comedy.
I'm sorry,
August 2nd.
I'll be at the comedy works in uh,
Denver,
Colorado and uh,
August 14th through the 17th,
I'll be at the Improv in Miami.
Then I got a bunch of other dates coming up cause right on the 23rd of August,
my,
uh,
my specialist coming out and then I'm going to be doing a tour and information
will be coming out soon.
All right,
so keep the questions coming.
Let me know how you guys think the story.
Sometimes I think the stories are good.
Sometimes I think kind of slows me down from a joking around.
I don't know if they're boring or if they're interesting,
please let me know.
Please give me a feedback.
I'll probably regret saying that because now I'm going to get a bunch of yeah,
and you stutter too much during them and blah,
blah blah.
So what,
why would I open myself up to more criticisms in life?
Anyways,
thanks everybody.
I really appreciate all you guys listening.
I know I say I only have 14 listeners.
I know it's a lot more than that.
It's gotta be at least 32 at this point and I really appreciate that.
You guys keep telling me that you like them.
As long as you're telling me you keep liking him,
I'm going to keep doing them and feeling like a man.
You don't have to fuck and listen,
I don't know why I have this hippie thing today.
Uh,
all right.
That's it.
That's the Monday morning podcast.
God bless all of you and it's off to Chicago and let's win there.
I'll talk to you guys.
Uh,
what the fuck is it next Monday.
All right,
happy July 4th weekend.
God bless America and uh,
you know,
stop taking shit from American Airlines and other airlines and stop taking shit
from these corporations.
Go to the West websites and complain.
Use a lot of words like outrageous,
ridiculous,
trying to go to a privately own shit.
That's what I like doing.
I tried to do that.
Then you go in there and they shit all over the food,
all over the spoon.
I mean,
this is food all over the spoon.
God just fucking,
this is why you know,
most people when they read the dyslexic,
I like to speak in dyslexia.
This is why I became a comedian.
If you have a fucking wondered why.
This is why I did it,
because I'm too much of a moron to exist in the real world.
And secondly,
when I'm in the real world,
um,
I like,
I just keep hearing this voice over and over.
I'm just going,
this is fucking stupid.
This is fucking stupid.
Fucking stupid.
That's all I would hear.
You know,
I tried to sit in the meetings as they talked about how to make the product
better and to try and increase the revenues.
And everyone was sitting there and they had out little little notebook cause it
was the eighties early nineties,
and he'll fucking writing shit down.
I just,
that's why I couldn't hear what the person was saying because my brain just kept
going.
This is fucking stupid.
I don't want to do this.
I don't wanna fucking do this.
Alright,
I don't fucking do this.
All right,
there you go.
That's my job history.
Before I became a comedian who was me doing one job after another and hearing a
loud voice in my head going,
I don't want to fucking do this.
So I don't,
and now I do this and this is too long.
All right,
I'll talk to you next week.
Have a great week.
Bye.
Oh,
hey.
okay.